Y ahora vamos a seguir trabajando
con las leyes de los exponentes.
Y vamos a seguir obteniendo dos de ellas
que son para mí de mis favoritas.
Estás leyes de los exponentes primero
vamos a verlas para un caso particular,
y después podemos pensar en ellas en un caso general,
y para esto vamos a utilizar todas las propiedades que ya nos sabemos.
Así que empezamos a trabajar con dos números.
Imagínate que mi primer número se llama "a"
y mi otro número le voy a poner el nombre de "b".
Ok, tengo a "a" por "b" y a estos 2 los quiero elevar,
los quiero elevar a la cuarta potencia.
A estos dos los quiero elevar a la cuarta potencia.
¿Cómo puedo obtener
el resultado de esto que tengo aquí?
Bueno, pues utilicemos las definiciones
que ya nos sabemos.
Esto es exactamente lo mismo...
y ahora déjame atrapar a estos dos,
para poderlos utilizar
de una manera más rápida,
esto me va a quedar Ctrl+C , "ab"
¡Ok! Me va a quedar a éste, multiplicado por sí mismo 4 veces...
Ok, por este...
Ok...
Y a esto lo vamos a multiplicar una vez más.
Ok, y a esto lo voy a multiplicar otra vez más
entonces me queda,
"a" por "b", por "a" por "b",  por "a" por "b", por "a" por "b"
y bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo,
y aquí podemos utilizar, que podemos conmutar las letras y entonces me quedaría "a"...
"a" por "a", por "a", por "a"
y después a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por "b", por "b", por "b"
por "b"
de tal manera
que tengo 4 veces a "a" multiplicándose
y puedo concluir que esta parte de aquí, es exactamente lo mismo que tener a "a" elevado a la cuarta potencia,
"a" por "a", por "a", por "a",
es lo mismo que "a" elevado a la cuarta potencia,
y esto a su vez está multiplicando a "b"...
a "b" multiplicándose por sí misma 4 veces
lo cual me da "b" elevada también a la cuarta potencia...
"b" elevada a la cuarta potencia
y justo a lo que estoy llegando
es que "a" por "b",
esto que tengo aquí,
elevado a la cuarta potencia...
elevado a la cuarta potencia,
es exactamente lo mismo
que "a" elevado a la cuarta potencia
por "b" elevado a la cuarta potencia,
y bueno, si tú te das cuenta
aquí tome el 4 como un número al azar
pero también ya lo podemos pensar
de una manera un poco más general,
nosotros podemos decir
que "a" por "b"...
"a" por "b"
elevado a cualquier potencia...
y se me ocurre no sé,
tomarme a "a" por "b elevado a la potencia "c",
esto es exactamente lo mismo
que "a" elevado a la "c"...
que "a" elevado a la potencia "c"
y a su vez esto multiplicado por "b"
elevado también a la potencia "c"...
también a la potencia "c"
y bueno, en la demostración te puedes dar cuenta
que es muy parecido a esto que tenemos aquí,
y en este vídeo no solamente quiero ver esta propiedad que se me hace muy importante,
sino que también quiero ver otra propiedad más de las leyes de los exponentes.
Pero para esto imagínate que
yo me tomo a un número "a",
yo me voy a tomar a "a"
¿Ok? Y a esta "a" la voy a elevar,
la voy a elevar a la potencia,
se me ocurre al cubo
y después voy a elevar esto...
y déjame copiarlo de una vez,
voy a elevar esto de aquí...
copiar de una vez...
voy a elevar esto de aquí
todo a la potencia 2...
a la potencia 2.
¿Qué voy a obtener de esta operación que tengo aquí?
Bueno pues vamos a utilizar otra vez las leyes de los exponentes, para ver qué me queda de esto
"a" al cubo, al cuadrado pues es lo mismo que tomarme "a" al cubo, déjame ponerlo justo aquí,
y a esto multiplicarlo por "a" al cubo...
y a esto multiplicarlo por "a" al cubo,
es justo la definición de un cuadrado.
Esto es "a" cúbica por "a" cúbica
y esto es exactamente lo mismo.
Nosotros sabemos que cuando tenemos
una base elevada a una potencia,
por una base elevada a otra potencia o la misma,
la potencia se conserva ¿Ok? Me quedaría "a"
elevado a la suma de las 2 potencias,
es decir me va a quedar 3... 3 más 3,
que por cierto, esto es exactamente lo mismo,
y lo voy a escribir así
como "a" elevado a la sexta potencia...
"a" elevado a la sexta potencia.
Ahora date cuenta que 3 más 3,
esto de aquí lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera,
3 más 3 es lo mismo que tomarme 2 veces 3,
ó 2 por "a" por 3.
Dicho de otra manera,
que lo que hicimos aquí fue empezar
con "a" elevado al cubo
y a esto lo llevamos a su vez al cuadrado,
y nos dimos cuenta que es multiplicar las potencias
2 por 3 es 6
y llegamos a la conclusión de que es
"a" elevada a la sexta potencia.
Ok, tal vez ya sea hora de ponerlo de una forma más general.
Si yo tengo a "a" elevado...
no sé, a la potencia "b"...
elevado a la potencia "b"
y esto a su vez elevado a la potencia "c"...
y esto a su vez elevado a la potencia "c",
esto va a ser igual
y bueno yo me podría tomar este "a" elevado a la "b"...
vamos a tomarlo,
"a" elevado la "b" es esta parte de aquí,
ok y vamos a ponerla  "c" veces,
entonces me va a quedar una vez por acá, ok...
otra vez por acá, ok...
otra vez por acá...
ok...
y nos podemos seguir manteniendo
haciendo esto mismo.
Yo me puedo tener aquí puntitos,
voy a multiplicar cuantas veces sea necesario,
"a" elevado a la "b"
hasta llegar a "c" veces
y aquí voy a tener de nuevo a "a" elevado a la "b",
para que en total de todas las veces que estamos multiplicando a "a" a la "b", sean "c" veces.
Entonces de aquí a acá tengo "c" veces
multiplicándose a "a" a la "b", "c" veces...
y bueno, déjame bajar un poco la pantalla.
Puedo decir ahora...
bajemos un poco la pantalla...
algo más o menos como por aquí,
que esto de aquí es exactamente lo mismo...
esto es exactamente lo mismo,
que tomarme a "a"
y a la vez las potencias se van a sumar,
esto es "a" elevado a la "b" más "b" más "b",
y así me puedo continuar,
sumando y sumando y sumando...
tantas veces como "c" veces sea necesario,
es decir,
"b" más "b", más "b"... "c" veces.
Dicho de otra manera, aquí tengo la suma de "b"
consigo misma "c" veces
porque aquí tengo "a" elevado a la "b", "c" veces
o dicho de otra manera,
como aquí tengo "c" veces a "b" sumándose,
entonces puedo concluir que esto
es exactamente lo mismo
que "a" elevado a la potencia "b"...
elevado a la potencia "b"
y a su vez multiplicado esta "b" multiplicada por "c",
entonces "a" elevado a la "b" elevado a su vez a la "c"
es exactamente lo mismo
que "a" elevado a la "b" por "c"
¡Muy bien! Aquí está otra de las leyes de los exponentes que me parece muy importante.
Porque inclusive podemos ver algún ejemplo,
imagínate que nosotros tenemos
a... se me ocurre 35...
35 elevado... elevado al cubo
y esto, y esto a su vez
lo elevamos a la potencia número 7
y bueno quiero que te des cuenta
que 35 elevado al cubo,
elevado a la 7 es un número un muy grande,
pero realmente lo que quiero es que apliquemos
el concepto que acabamos de ver.
Esto es exactamente lo mismo que 35... que 35,
y ahora voy a simplificar un poco las potencias.
Estas dos potencias las voy a juntar multiplicándolas
3 por 7 es 21
y entonces es mucho mejor ver
35 elevado a la potencia 21
que 35 elevado al cubo, elevado a la potencia número 7, ¡y ya está!
Acabamos de ver una forma mucho más simplificada
de obtener una respuesta utilizando,
lo que acabamos de ver con
las leyes de los exponentes.